hey there hey there hey there hey there hey
there think of my headphones for this
hey there Leonardo Leonardo Leonardo
Leonardo
just call me Izzy dizzy dizzy Izzy
you know what I do I have in my left ear is
wrong my speakers I don't know what
I'm sure ocean it sorry I don't know what
the fuck is going on
I'm going to blow out of everybody's ears
out I don't know what the hell
where can I get the mic back
check once again I can get the mic back and
then like I know how to get back to that's
fine
and Mike is really weird
how to make a new medical center you don't
have to watch I just I'm just going to. I
was just drinking beer actually
but when I find there's like a lot of noise
on the on the thing
what is doing is combining the noise help